I think it's been you know quite amazing
that for 12 years it's accomplished but
I think it has no relation to anything
okay in other words it moves it has no
relation it's a tiny thing that gets a
disproportionate attention you know the
value of crypto cryp uh Bitcoin is less
than a third of the value of Microsoft
stock you could go into Industries but
biotech and many other Industries are
more interesting than Bitcoin it's not
going to be an effective money it's not
an effective storeold of wealth it's not
an effective medium of exchange but we
are in a world in which money as we know
it is in Jeopardy right we are printing
too much and it's not just the United
States all the reserve currencies the
what's going on in euroland what's going
on in Yen and so in that world the
question is what is money and how's that
going to operate so when we look at
something like China's remb and then you
take the digital REM andb um I think
you're going to see that become more and
more a thing